let's let's go right to my first  question you never dressed this way on  my show I don't think I've ever seen you  wear a dress and you've been on many  times and I this is the way you usually  appear on the show that's a picture of  your normal what made you decide this  time I'm gonna go with the mind reader I  just want to know how I died well as you  know I suffer from an agoraphobia which  is the fear of wearing anything feminine  normally but while I was in Palm Springs  I tried some ayahuasca tea mm-hmm and it  totally changed me right really yes I  have now I am embracing my inner drag  queen yeah I'm loving it I think you  look amazing  inside this big bull dyke body beats the  heart of a vicious queen honey will you  look lovely thank you  you